bonjour linda linda maintenant c'est le
moment des enfants oui un moment que je
chéris particulièrement linda il faut à
nous dire concupiscence quand tu puisses
ans les genres
j'ai invité de marque aujourd'hui à
l'invité d'une droiture exceptionnel un
chanteur que la particulièrement dénommé
serge gainsbarre
bonjour ça va bien je suis content que
nos jeunes talents c'est après chanson
she et maintenant tout de suite aux avis
cette marque
les enfants c'est pas conclure c'est pas
ton tour laissé le micro
bonjour je commence tout à fait qu'audi
d'appel candidats peinent l'abîmé
l'animé la d'hemingway tu vas à l'école
la limite nous tu fais un sport a dit me
oui qu'est ce que tu fais comme ça la
brusque suis pas nous montrer ce qu'il
sait faire c'est bien la lumière merci
le dire qu'est ce que tu vas nous
chanter ne servent qu'à se battront
santé coûtent entre elles tissent entre
la balade est adéquat répéter je pige
avec orange
suma cette petite non c'est pas votre
rendement bonjour monsieur comment tu
t'appelles caroline et on en sait quoi
et bernal y est ainsi faite en paix il
coupe
il est là dans la salle naipaul moment
elle est là oui là-bas elle est où tu
peux la rentrée là bas on va pas non
mon vrai papa il a vu pas là si toi tu
n'es pas au bonjour je ne
bonjour bonjour comme un guide a fait
pipi viennent sans peine non on aurait
voulu tap les mêmes
quelle question de faire manger à la
maison de nous sinon pas de nous
je voudrais pas manger des fruits non
c'est pas des fêtes et sur habité nous
nous y sommes
exemple à l'école howie d'avoir plein de
copines homo vous fait des copines
oui y en a beaucoup comment il s'appelle
ça mais moi je n'appelle supprimer 5 et
nationales sur les t-shirts que tu
touches à celui qui a fait un bisou
c'est cette fois une heure dans tomb
raider
amélie tu vas me manquer howie tu bois
tu vois le mieux avec le costume saumon
avec la gourmette en or et qui sent bon
et ben c'est le gros qui bob à côté
c'est un moment ta maman celle adaptée à
côté du nom c'est pas ma maman maman
c'est le monsieur avec good things we
will ferrell
on va la rentée coup 8e ma petite iq est
100 de ma braguette jupe ici je paie ton
monte aussi quatre n'ont été aussi gaz à
tous les étages
ford qui ont connu notre katarina witt
accor cède 0,7
oui aussi maintenant c'est aux médecines
36 sélections
tu vas les crimes n'ont pas idée dans la
salle ta maman c'est pas un peu bêta
personnes ça se casse pas 10 dons
commandites ap
comment tu t'appelles
jane a c'est un joli prénom savait
comment madame son bien et reste loi 39
ans et ça fait bien sûr expliqué que ce
n'est pas pour cette émission aussi
venus voter pour un croyant même
allez les gazelles au bouillon là on va
faire chauffer la source
lala pas trop chaud thermostat 8
mosaïque pas mettre un peu plus bas dans
les jambes ono moi je les aime bien les
tubes et parler un peu moins ça vous
changera vous dirai moins de bêtises je
reviens quand j'me moi je suis des gens
super je vous dirais ai dit si vous
voyez de la fumée vous me prévenez 1
huawei bouzid s'est passé votre vie face
envolez vous me prévenez aussi hein
qu'est ce qui fait chaud ça me rappelle
mes vacances au maroc
moi ça serait plutôt je trouve ça unix
messam rappeur le plus tôt la mousson
aux indes à bord et laisser les armes
non mais je vais beaucoup de films avec
des indiens et cow-boys me parlez pas de
folles ça me rappelle la culotte de
cheval que sera mal depuis 20 ans
moi j'en ai marre a ici un peu plus
parler de rien quand je parle de cinéma
me dit ça me rappelle ma culotte de
cheval
quand je parle de plage on dit ça me
rappelle mes bruit quand je parle de
voitures invitées toi te rappeler les
pneus autour de la taille
alors de quoi faut que je parle ici mais
vous énervez pas je dis ça comme ça pour
dire que journal excusez moi madame
excusez moi mais l'archange et fulham et
lyonnaise et prend vite
ne prononcez pas ce nom en mayonnaise
ces mots que j mignon j'en avais jamais
avec tout de la mayonnaise avec avec des
crudités avec du saucisson avec la
choucroute avec des frites mayonnaise
parlez pas de friture ça se trouve nous
abrutit la même à nous laisser tout ça
alors les monstres henry seul
c'était un peu chaud ouais je baise si
je veux comme je veux pas je baisserai
pas le charbon est agréable il est
vraiment pas agréable moi je trouve un
peu en plus qu'est-ce qui les villes à
vis à vis à vis six prêts qui font ça
c'est pour qu'on soit pas distraire
pendant la cure je veux dire moi et
doctorat parce que moi attaché amoureuse
je maigris caché jusque là ce qu'il faut
là oui faute de partants c'est juste
bien si vous voulez pourra du
maître-chien amoureuse maigrir dès qu'il
est plus amoureuse grosse île ah oui
vous savez si vous faites ça s'appelle
de la gonflette psychologique
voilà moi j'ai un peu du genre accordéon
si vous voulez gellé souffert mais j'ai
quand même moins de boutons alors moi je
serais plutôt du genre contrebas soyez
c'est à dire comme un petit peu serrées
à la taille mais alors bien enflé de la
caisse va y est et chez vous dira pour
faire fondre tous à eybens l'archipel
toujours à voter en fait on le dit chez
nous vaut mieux faire envie que pitié
ça vous avez raison à qui mangent 1,9 me
ouais mais qui dort dîne exactement mais
c'est ça mon problème moi voyez pas ce
que je suis insomniaque
donc je dors pas donc je dîne pas donc
j'ai tout enfant donc je passe ma nuit à
manger assez monsieur
alors ce jour où ce sera très rapide
juste cinq minutes avant et non de sa
propre personne qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui vous ont proposé à vous comme régime
est comme moi c'est un régime à base
d'algues si vous voulez qu'il nous
apporte à tous les repas des plateaux de
fruits de mer
mais l'idée pas droite touchée aux
coquillages faut manger juste la
garniture les glaçons qu'est ce que je
vous disais
ils ont su drôlement efficace à je suis
parent mais dites que vous avez déjà
fait le
de maigrir en groupe alors qu'ils se
serrent assez formidable voyez c'est
dire que le sait c'est vachement
stimulant parce qu'on se pose tous
ensemble exit ensemble l'ip est c'est la
menace pèse chacun tout seul oui tout le
monde regarde si l'aiguillé montée des
cendriers ici alors ils font des
commentaires
alors au début ça me plaisait bien parce
que ça aide vous voyez mais à la rage
urgent avait repris une petites rondeurs
voyez 10 20 kg et bailly toute la
journée m'a appelé gros tas gros boudin
100 % de matière grasse manger abandonné
à jour comprend la vérité ça fâche à du
don
ça va vous est le petit pot de saintdo
lula
pour maigrir ou alors vous venez chez
pol et les promenades romantiques au
clair de lune sur la plage ils sont les
rochers à nero sur ce coup là j'en mange
avec toy des tartines beurrées avec la
confiture se tremper lancer dans le
cacao ces jeunes gars a dit j'espère
qu'il va nous délivrer parce que la
cocotte minute et commence explose il a
ouais je sais pas s'ils ont maigri mais
en tout cas on va être propre parce que
entre legranger entre les bains
bouillonnants entre le sauna qu'est-ce
qu'on élimine comme crassat mais qu'est
ce qui fait alors rien que on se prépare
pour poser la foire du trône il va nous
délivrer quand même c'est pas encore
cuit parce qu'en terme et il va nous lis
ici tout le week end trouve en masse
rouge qu'au niveau encadrement c'est
déplorable et en plus un c'est cher je
vais vous dire moi on mange plus on paye
cher c'est vrai et en plus ces
distractions c'est nul et nous aide pas
psychologiquement mais vous avez raison
mais moi j'étais à la bibliothèque
lierre vous savez premier bouquin sur
lequel je suis tombé qu'est ce que c'est
fait non les français sous l'occupation
bon alors je me dis ça ça va être bien
c'est un truc anodin mais pas du tout à
toutes les pages parle de rutabaga de
toppi non
de pommes de terre et comment obtenir
des double ticket de rationnement
comment obtenir des offres au marché
noir et sinon ce bouquin ça parle de
bouffe tout le temps moi je vous dis
rien qu'à lire j'ai pris deux kilos et
en plus quand je pense qu'ils se
plaignent à chaque page
courageux grands pas et les films vous
avez vu les films qui nous passent des
films d'amour alors vas-y que je
t'invite au restaurant pas séduit
allez que je fais de bons petits plats
y'a qu'un truc que j'ai pour vous aimer
si le documentaire sur le biafra mais
vous savez qu'elles ont raison d'être
masse comme ça la borde basse yeux si
j'enlève balade tout nu
ce serait ridicule s'il y avait de la
cellulite de la région d'avoir celle de
la minceur
je vous dirais kg tout ça si c'est dans
la tête
ah oui il faut assumer ce qu'on
trimballe à faut pas croire qu'une femme
comme jane birkin par exemple elle est
plus heureuse que nous mais comment mais
la preuve ne sait pourquoi il buvait gaz
ou non mais c'est parce qu'elle était
trop maigre
ça pour rendre la pétanque il a pu ma
bouche il a bien fallu dix ans est
partout en guest rachitique
mais vous n'y a pas qu'elle regarde des
demis roussos lui quand il était gros
ils changeaient bien des pays la mairie
de saint roch qu'ils ont le voit plus à
la télé mais il faut garder nos pilotage
politique nationale et veut garder nos
rangs d'anciens mais ce qui va nous
arriver c'est moi qui débranchent les
rôtissoires 50 grammes en moins chacune
à bout ça se voit marcher un peu
et bien non c'est pire l'apéritif trois
noyaux d'olives un verre d'eau de mer
chacune employés les deux éléphants
suivant
moi les gonzesses
comme ça je vous dit james dean du clark
des vols due aux travaux garde ça dans
ma cage taradeau moustapha ben bio c'est
bien du sport à l'âge alors je vais te
montrer c'est bien vous voulez que
capitaine courageux rouvrir à la main à
travers tous ces silhouettes que l'on
distingué dans la pénombre
excusez moi excusez moi je me dirigeais
vers ses cales et être enfin de
nouvelles waliboo
quoi qu'il en soit j'ai bel accueil
jeanne est bel et bien celui enfin le
crac averti jeu proposé à ma production
de lui offrir un verre asie je leur
donne puisqu'il faudra des glaçons est
pour moi un double whisky nature sans
glaçons avec une part je lui parlais de
rien elle me parlait de tout bref on
parlait de rien du tout mais j'attendais
avec impatience moment crucial probité
sur la piste il manquait évidemment
l'atmosphère adéquat
le slow alors on fêtera d'ailleurs pour
les se refaire une petite beauté
je la voyais dans son égoïsme cuir
caoutchouc
qui se dandine m
holnon ce rythme disco la petite nahla
number one dans l'état laisse repeindre
la façade dans les toilettes comme au
support mois les landaises
il n'y a pas de racisme c'est que sa
fille c'est important le petit truc qui
fait le branchant le saut ne se fit pas
attendre
et moi non plus dès les premières
notions je sentais que mon n'a pas
succombé instantanément ce méfait comme
une aspirine et indécente dans un peu
d'eau
et crois moi jamais mais qu'on cesse
tandis qu'autour de nous les
gloutonnerie labiale dont il s'est de
plus en plus
j'obtiens enfin une initiative ma main
qui était stationné depuis un quart
d'heure source à ces langues qui s'est
maintenant droite avant vous dire d'une
sensualité plus significatives papoul à
cet effet je sentais d'ailleurs la
chaleur de son corps on va dire comme
une brève du bout des doigts qui répond
prix au vu de la chute du mur
le torch vivant de s'élancer en dhr
j'étais bien
un petit gémissement s'est fait entendre
comme un cri de plaisir et s'échappe
vainement d'un accord en fusion oui mais
est bouillonnante sans tarder un couru à
son cou un baiser langoureux s'échappa
ainsi de 13 c'était dans la poche
la soirée ne faisait que commencer
maintenant fallait assurer moi les
gonzesses comme ça à peine avions nous
relier le tube digestif geste brutal me
séparer de ma compagne nancy nice ont
aussitôt je constate un terme à des
faveurs que j'avais à faire aux
concubins de ma concubine dilemme on
l'était 2 sur le coup le regard de
l'assistance vive hier sur moi
jallet pouvait en aucune manière nous
sauver comme un lâche et mettre en pause
pendant ce temps de mal
malgré son allure athlétique je
résistais décidé c'était lui ou moi moi
les conseils scrutin
je te plairait d'avoir à mon égard une
certaine retenue dit énervé pas moins en
été l'air déçu les analystes et le
manque de respect évident non aussi ils
sont aussitôt j'ai utilisé ma technique
d'intimidation par les faits ils en
foutent rend pas la vie en somme lui
démontrer qu'il avait fermé de la tour à
before pluie papa tu parles il était bon
d'en décider le conte agression
flagrante
j'étais dans tous les états jacques
unissait sa turbine et dans les méninges
ça fumait ça peut-être vous voulez
c'était la guerre pas grave je gagnais
de dire parfois ouais bah oui là
alors là il avait deviné mes faiblesses
sont au pied d'ailleurs fait
volontairement et avec une violence des
éléments vitaux d'un homme normalement
constitué
mais ben gayer solitaire moi c'est
l'assaillant je continue avec courage ma
douleur et croyez moi j'avais ma morale
devant de nouveaux jeux constater sans
surprise comme l'agresseur avait fui
avec sa comparse a acheté des barricades
peur et kurt waldheim mépris total
pouvait se lire sur mon visage mais
j'avais toujours là
conséquence fatale de l'ironie du sort
vainqueur du mans en fiche m'en fiche
cet échec ne faisait que confirmer mon
succès qu'on se le dise asine de
tamanrasset à juvisy de ouarzazate à
rambouillet mois les bons 16 watts
quelque chose d'un petit peu habillée et
que je vous lis on cherche on cherche un
pur tout qu'est ce qu'on va lui mettre à
part les sacs poubelle elle a tout
essayé
dépêchez vous de la wii écoute il faut
quelque chose pour ce soir apple voilà
madame nous avons trouvé voilà notre
dernière création bois c'est pas mal
cette origine il fait passer tout de
suite voilà vous mettez à kiwi
oui ça va aller ça allez viens viens je
remplis assez mais évidemment si ça
déborde vous ne pourrez plus faire et
puis ça fera pas traîné écoutez je suis
emmerdé
alors c'est normal oui parce que je
grossis en ce moment on s'en fout
complètement
merci est-ce qu'il ya d'autres styles en
a par la suite d'écoutés aucun problème
on a tout l'état on va jusqu'au sang
jusqu'au sang oui évidemment jusqu'aux
100 livres envoyés
marie-pierre on essaie trognon vous
aller nous chercher des trucs par là
vous savez avec nicole nous avons voulu
faire déjà méfaits du jamais vu nous
appelons ce petit ensemble sacs
poubelles
écoutez personnellement ce qui me
concerne oui je joue a bien vu dans une
octave
ah oui et bien non et non madame mais
oui ça me désole mais ça n'existe qu'en
driller plus à ses standards et à partir
des grandes feuilles nous ne faisons
plus que dans le gris j'ai balancé page
aurait coûté une chaleur son rythme avec
l'espagne transpire
mais la dame 1 non madame mais non vous
ce n'est pas de la transpiration un
chevreuil nos sacs poubelles vous fait
émettre une très fine vapeur d'eau qui
dilate les pores de la peau pour la
débarrasser de ses moindres impuretés
sur madame vous voyez que ça n'a
vraiment rien à voir avec de la
transpiration parmi eux joué du tout
dites moi qu'est ce que je vais mettre
comme chaussures avec un salomé
alors faire vous savez nous avons les
boots qui colle avec l'ensemble je suis
toute une collection itunes et
maintenant je veux bien j'ai écouté tout
se vend on a fait tout ce monde a
également les pies noires bien les draps
et double ridoré oula oula
et puis les parfois aussi les parfums sa
courageuse elle a par la suite la crs
est pour dans les airs issus ou l'espère
au marché un petit peu pour la rue mais
si vous permettez ça vous donne les
monts du glacis mais les problèmes vont
à droite oui je le perds un peu le
talent je passerais bien la petite demie
on se voyait au nom vous savez si vous
mettez une petite socket par exemple
savoir la bonne micro chaussettes
labonal bien son rang il faut suivre les
faits et la sacra rien comme arctic 109
ans est totalement étanche oui mais
voilà le pied court le pied dedans oui
ça va je sais jouir la neige et
s'amusent sous la pluie la qualité le
sad poupe se voir écouter madame j'irai
même plus loin la qualité de sa coupe se
vit n'est ce pas nicole et moi je dirais
même plus c'est une seconde peau vers la
ville labellisée j'ai un vernissage ce
soir je le mets directement comme ça il
y aura beaucoup de monde mon mari va
accrocher enfin écoutez madame s'il ya
du monde et en plus la chaleur je vais
vous dire que votre mari fera plus que
d'accrocher pour vous même à des rivaux
samedi
entre vous ce soir ça va très fort
collins vous poser une question à poser
ricol rien ne pose aucun problème du
tout mais combien pardon oui le prix de
ce ravissant offrir à louis marie pierre
aux alumineries alors le bustier vous
fera mille la jupe 2000
oui il est bouilli vous ce mec me l'a
annoncé hier d'une ue pour un petit
ensemble qui est pas mal
ricker oui complètement au lieu c'est
vrai qu est-ce qu il est emmené petit
aguichant parisien petit b brillant
parisien petit sol et craquant parisien
sur petit et délirant par ici a
évidemment j'ai ri à parier la petite
tête fellini au parisien jeudi jugent
arrêt la petite et mieux pour mes
copains coûter chère madame surtout pour
qu'aucun oui vous avez tout de suite
soit le côté pratique de cette poule
faut par exemple vous voulez ramener
quelques toasts vous les mettez dans
chaque poule
voilà et puis en arrivant chez vous vous
mettez le tout offre et sa coupe
directement au frigo ça fait super moi
ou pas c'est complètement polyvalent
comme un simple écran est mort le
lendemain avons retenu reste fraîche on
va juste un petit coup d'épaulé c'est
impeccable
j'entends bien je peux répondre est une
éponge grattoir pour malades quand je
viens à la planche comme ça sera bien
pour moi je crois que sa poupe ça va
être pas tant les avais madame cinq
coupes c'est la puissance industrielle
au service de bruxelles
oui merci
à l'écouter oui je vais le prendre et
puis je me dépêchais manquent pas
martèle sisters vous inquiétez pas il ya
la belle qui passe à 6 heures
je suis emballé à oui ça c'est les
rebelles et américaines madame est
emballé et encore des demandes
d'engagement vallée je le prends en est
d'ailleurs le même le garder si on
regarde je suis plein du jour eh bien
écoutez madame si vous êtes plein on va
redescendre
c'est à dire quinze jours qu'on roule à
combler super tiens j'en profitais pour
vérifier la liste
ok ok c'est parti coton tige hockey
papier est ok after shave poupée coca et
non bien sûr
je prends le risque attention virage à
droite partition qu'il n'est pas fini de
sécher je sais depuis longtemps mais
qu'est ce que tu fous là et bien là
attention aux piétons trois ter san
indigènes ont augmenté leurs prix vous
avez des tapis des grêlons faudrait
signaler aux organisateurs des plus
riches ralenti droite et habitants sont
pas comme il a dit oui ça sent la
merguez un couscous ah ouais quand même
matthew rusch le fleuve ya pas de
problème en fait c'est qu'elle soit
blanc brillant que celui d'accor et des
quoi il ya un problème là j'ai vu m'a
répondu ah bon on va pas dire rien ils
ont construit récemment la narration des
chansons c'est défendre quoi vais je
dire je fais pareil dakar ya cinq ans
cette édition des champs de maïs
maintenant attendu reconnaître avec le
fric qu'on envoie c'est mon refuge en
france serait plus longtemps il s'achète
même des bagnoles savent pas s'en servir
c'est ça ma pelle on appelle la concorde
aux heures de pointe
j'écoutais la radio n'a pas dû dire
c'est le 6 de deux jeunesses en
direction de port bien que la france ait
un hôpital au lion on abaisse la marche
il bouge pas face et l'afrique ça oui
ali d'enfer sur lyon tu m'invites
impression qu'ils ont marqué la fois
d'accord je supporte pas les lions enfin
ces bonheurs jédir brasseur va la boyne
tous derrière à barrois sera pas bras
toujours des trucs et par dessus la
jambe pour aller à dakar
ouais non pas les gars à dakar ah
d'accord
qu'est ce qu'il a dit vas y attendais
pas je suis coincé il a regardé en est
on arrivé là
mais surtout elle va attraper froid je
supporte la maison des fous rires avec
leur banque
yvan [ __ ] ouais mais bon bon écoute
quand j'ai demandé un supplément d'âme
pendant mademoiselle monsieur
dakar 7 à combien oui combien 1500 3000
à 2 l et es je crois qu'on n'est pas
arrivé
tu as on s'y plaît à les fraises
merci la demi panaché
mouchoirs
vous avez un problème vous voulez
peut-être que je vous aide il est
beaucoup plus facile de parler à
quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas raconté
j'ai rencontré la femme de ma vie
monsieur l'été belle ses cheveux blonds
ses yeux marrons c'est au corps
magnifique si vous saviez tout pas comme
ça l'était elle a pleuré à l'étude à
l'oralité corps
double problème les femmes j'ai pas leur
parler
white cube est en baisse
benzema comme ça vous parle en forme
avant volontaire des gentillesses de la
poésie vos beaux yeux me font mourir
d'amour au oui si je dise où ils ont la
suavité de manger des tropiques je sais
pas la splendeur de nuit attendaient
atteint 18,2 t
le cil invité le propice au métro pie ix
et met d'accord c'est pas vous aimez
voyager nous a été en vacances ou une
tombe où elle apparaît nue les jambes ou
par volonté du cambodge était petit
oui baloji ya pas de famille ici
profiter au mieux des voix
bonjour vous appelez comment vous
connaissez le luxe en vo non alors
obèses
ah oui mais ce que vous attendiez aussi
à oui bientôt on brime pensait bien en
plus ils vont changer de place parce
qu'il y avait garé pour lire les pensées
de passe
j'attends j'attends pourquoi vous vous
inquiétez c'est quand même un événement
à part l avènement c'est pas la première
fois que ça m'arrive mais ben justement
moi je n'ai 3g et à chaque fois c'est la
jouer encore plus grand ça doit être
douloureux
un peu pour ma femme
à début mai après vous savez moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que mine et jaune mais
je peux votre femme amélie elle est
noire pourquoi ah oui là vous avez
raison de s'inquiéter parce que j'ai
fait un peu de musique parce que par
exemple louis mois avec moi oui ça fait
noir oui si les îles et jaune
il faudrait que je sois y est verte et
bleue pourquoi la boîte elle était de
couleur blanche mois les besoins pour
moi je suis blanc lé les blancs ça fait
des blocs c'est aussi comme ça qu'on
peut vérifier parce que s'ils étaient de
couleur
c'est pas normal non plus à
l'hémoglobine et tout ça parce que moi
j'ai de la chance parce que moi et la
semaine dernière fois je l'aï attrapée
aussi il ya deux ans j'ai été sauvé à
temps parce qu'ils ont détecté et milan
vue au microscope
c'est à prématuré alors ils étaient tous
mes gars la maison témoin non il ne m'a
pas j'ai fait ça dans ah ah oui c'est
gentil de parler saint-joseph aussi le
trouvait trop de trucs éprouvette là
comment je sais c'est pas très récent
d'avoir eu dix mois ne s'est pas très
bien sur l'autoroute s'est pas élancé
abbas a fait 9 mois et est alors on fait
ça allongé sur un lit ça doit près de
pratique
avec sa taille ou ap
laurent c'est parce que moi j'ai fait sa
douche bâtard de vous ah oui à la va
vite alors j'ai deux sentiments
vous avez été bien soigné à moi pas du
tout mais la femme est très contente on
revient tout le temps là bas c'est votre
femme qui est porteuse du qui vous a
fini le jeu ne va pas être comme chez
vous alors parce que
moi je dis comme ça s'est passé moi je
avec ma femme on est allé voir le
gynécologue
mais bon il nous a dit écoutez on va
faire comme d'habitude
ouais c'est une autre femme qui portera
le il dit du coup les hommes sera encore
très très donc voilà on a fait comme ses
terres parce que en ce qui me concerne
je sais pas si je suis un cas parce que
j'ai eu les premières douleurs il ya
deux mois
je vais vous dire moi je le savais pas
où ça se voit pas tellement
m oui je crois que le mien était
terminée
bon bah je ne referai une beauté moi ça
peut-être pas la beauté toute entière
parce que ça va prendre du temps
de fait un peu de rouge à lèvres
seulement ans puis non parce que si
jamais j'embrasse un mec par hasard dans
la voir partout autour de la mouche
alors après ces deux réflexions du genre
ouais t'as rouler un patin poule
je commence à vraiment ça fait ce teaser
que je suis là j'arrête pas de refuser
pas deux fois façon c'est dit c'est dit
le premier qui passe je me le fais le
premier jeu me
ouais bah le deuxième peut-être là
c'est de m'asseoir merci savons les
boîtes 1 1
ces savants on peut on veut se
rencontrer on apprend à se connaître
quoi hein
on peut se parler ces mines c'est
toucher bon tout le sérieux surtout non
ça va coûter moins de poser la question
du crime ans c'est la première fois que
vous voulez des noms mais c'est la
dernière commenté c'est entre les
extraterrestres dit ça creuse les arbres
côté normand enfin je veux dire ça me
regarde pas et votre dentiste je peux
dire du mal de temps vous pouvez moi
j'aime pas le montrer
et dans il vous a fait ça au noir n'ont
ils pas fait ça dans le noir bon bah je
vais faire un tour au bar mois obama
table la campagne 16 duels elles n'ont
pas sa feria je vais racheter un camp
mais c'est qu'on sera bien aller au bar
regarder comme ça je me regarde pas ce
que vous êtes the big ben a évidemment
si vous allez que vous comme point de
repère
moi je suis miss monde à moi peut-être
pas musulman mais vous pourriez gagner
des concours en facilement mais c'est
joli ça va mal et concours ça va mais
vous pouvez en faire un concours si vous
voulez vous êtes en effet dès maintenant
mais présentés au concours du plus beau
bébé quand on était petits on nous
aiguiller sur autre chose tout de suite
on nous a envoyés sur un concours
agricole fallait trouver plus conclut
noah j'ai gagné quelle belle coup c'est
une grosse claque à la maison j'ai une
coupe tous les amoureux de sa bien aimé
voir votre coupe c'est très bien mais
qui dit on l'attend pas en discutant
discute il sera peut-être temps de
rentrer chez vous un ah ben c'est pas
bête sanwi embrassez moi parce que je
savais j'arrivais d'appartements vous
savez faire moi même c'est un deux
pièces cuisine que j'ai tout bien avec
moquette électrique twizy une boucle et
le crédit personnalisé que des lanternes
d'étouffer aussi moi même des mots clés
des mois de baisse alors on s'emmerde
déjà assez ici on apprend les emmerder
chez vous non plus on peut peut-être sur
actions en voiture après c'était une
voiture et une belle voiture tenir vis
chez mon père c'est moi même fait une
superbe année
devenus des coussins derrière vous savez
plus reste est la question c'est bon
c'est directement mais il va me lâcher
je suis là oui le choc des mots à et pas
les postillons n'est pas faux de parler
avions une grenouille quoi ces composés
geignard était bonne de moi journée avec
les bell'a njoh ma compo taxe sera bien
oui
c'est un jour normalement de moyenne il
faut que je vous parle
voyez vous mademoiselle j'ai décidé de
j'ai décidé de fonder un foyer
mais je voudrais pas le fond des sols
avec qui et avec qui
ouais avec qui abbas et là ça va pas
être facile avec une femme madame ma
décision est prise
j'ai deux jours pour mon week-end je
vais quand même pas les gâcher bêtement
mais c'est sa façon personne même s'il
n'a pas marqué hier mais du star ici moi
j'ai ma soupe aux pois même qu'on fait
longtemps mais écoutez il ya des tas
gens un peu on peut vous répondre mini
gré doit françoise dolto déranger tout
ça tout de suite comme ça mais non mais
nivet voilà sûrement boîte de cette loi
n'est ni grégoire elle m'a dit moi le
jour où sortir en boîte ce moment
ferment
y'a que moi a sidéré mais voudra t pas
sûr mais lee vous braquez pas sûr mais
ne vous braquez pas sûr mais ni ça ne
sert à rien 1
moi ce que je suis sûr qu'à naples 1 des
femmes voudraient bien que vous
m'appelez je fais en a plein on n'y a
pas un chiffre précis c'est ça qu'ils
m'ont merde
non c'est un exil et l'intelligence dans
la rue mais c'est pas possible
mais on les laisse rentrer et on les
laisse dans les laits cela comme ça on
les habille on les nourrit à mais c'est
pas vrai mais faut les jeter
alors j'ai compris alors c'est parce que
je suis mince alors sous prétexte de lui
- et non plus mais vous seriez que moche
vous auriez qu'un manche bon moche bon
et ben stein est comme un bon non plus
vous êtes cons
ah bon et je suis sûr vous êtes pauvres
à bâle ont quand même pas bien froid
mais fanfare - il s'enfonce en plus
belle mais foutez moi dès lors que c'est
pas pire mais il paraît pauvre mâché
quand il m'accuse d'agen et de faire
deux mi temps
aujourd'hui notre nouvelle formule comme
jeunes dimanche matin et pour la
première fois à l'écran gili maintenir
avec aminés et bien voilà
je suis à grand david et je suis la
petite fille on n'a pas besoin d'être
suis pas besoin de fonds avec gym part
de l'icco resterait ronde a marre des
mains saint marc des mails a marre des
films et a cédé m'aide à thoiry et pour
conserver votre cellulite rester sans
bouger et manger des frites à toi vers
la wii aminés et pour répéter d'avant le
ventre plat pourra t on chez manger
beaucoup de 3 to do you do chez nous on
suit pas et on transpire pas ces
mythomanes sentir sous les bras
une chienne pour un peu mot nation vas-y
et pour éviter que vos seins se tiennent
en des soutiens gorge et virer votre
gain vous reste est assez et pas pour
vous grandir moi ga secret mais je veux
pas vous le dire mais pourquoi se
fatiguer s courbatures etc
toute la journée on passe du coup ces
trois commandes à sion
am ou supprimer votre taille de guêpe
manger les trois fin des gaufres et des
crêpes et pour pas d'avenir mme assez
bien foutu évitez surtout vous bouger le
tout eu lieu tôt
et bien voilà l'émission et lilly
j'espère tout avait bien suivi avinés et
perla vous salue et vous dimanche avec
au moins cinq ans de plus
autre appel à l'eau à nous oui allô
bonsoir madame diallo me falloir oui
madame
quel est votre prénom pire est oui
bonsoir pire des tiers est un prénom qui
chantent
pierrette sos coeurs brisés vous écoute
alors voilà j'ai 34 ans je vis avec un
homme caire depuis deux ans j'ai un
petit garçon aussi un giro qui a 5 ans
attendait pierrette donc pierre n'est
pas le père de jérôme si c'est le père
de cheyrou bien nous sommes d'accord
d'accord peut continuer je vous en prie
pierrette et détendez vous nous sommes
là pour vous aider et dites vous bien
que tout problème a une solution
merci merci donc je peux continuer la
wii et dites vous bien que tout problème
a une solution je peux continuer oui et
du clavier
alors voilà depuis quelques temps pierre
n'est plus le même avec moi on connaît
plus la voir ont changé d'attitude et
soyez plus précises pire s il vous plait
oui mais voilà c'est arrivé il ya deux
ou trois semaines à peu près qu'en dites
vous justement de nice s'est pas pu
grandir
non je demande quand est-ce arrivé il ya
deux ou trois semaines à peu près à
c'est important qu'ils arrêtent
oui bon alors donc ya deux ou trois
semaines pierre est rentré du travail
ont comme d'habitude puis on s'est
disputés mais vraiment alors pour une
bricole et puis je vous en prie
pierrette il me faut tous les paramètres
du conflit afin d'être à même d'élucider
votre problème problème d'une femme qui
veut s'en sortir et il me semble que
c'est votre cas pire est même bien sûr
bien sûr mais voilà pierre m'a frappé a
est depuis cette première fois ils ne
frappent régulièrement mis à
je suis très ennuyé parce que le pied là
ils assistent à ces scènes à a dit moi
pire est que fait pierre dans la vie
piet les routiers et pourtant les
routiers sont sympas
bien sûr je suis bien enfin que dois-je
faire les mines sylvette sylvette il va
t'il verspieren oui pierret qui respire
et pierrette a priori est
indubitablement et je suis sûr de ne pas
me tromper en mieux bien un problème
vous croyez oui écouter petit à gratin
nous nous trouvons manifestement devant
le 4 types de l'homme qui vit avec une
femme et un enfant
c'est ça et déjà nous y voyons plus
clair un homme est simple l enfant
c'était très sale et j me le dirait même
plus loin qui rêvent d'oeil aux on nous
pose la question quelle question au mini
vous êtes toujours la pierrette elle
souhaitait pas y arriver doucement y
arrive
chi va piano va sano vous le savez tir
être donc je ne savais pas si vous savez
alors posons nous poser la question oui
pourquoi
pourquoi vous fera peut-il bien sûr vous
êtes vous déjà posé cette question
intéresse et c'est pourquoi elle s'est
bien sûr aussi pourquoi pas posée mais
la réponse est dans la main la réponse
dans la marmite alors pourquoi oui bien
sûr je comprends tout à fait mais quand
même de norme donc résumons résume
pierre frappe pierrette devant pierre
devant jérôme qui n'est pas l'enfant de
pierre si un père celle perdue en
arrière nous sommes d'accord et je pense
que muni de toutes ces informations
je peux le dire pierre s'identifie
totalement un jérôme cet enfant que vous
frappez alors petit je le touche passé
sans savoir une frappe
et rien d'autre bien d'autres pierrette
on intervient dans ce problème que deux
points ouvrez les guillemets pierre
jérôme et jérôme pierre fermez les
guillemets ça s'en va et ça revient
c'est fait de tous petits riens bien sûr
et déjà envoyé je crois que c'est un rip
direct a alors dit auxdites ouf ouf
pierrette je veux vous l'entendre dire
c'est très bien attirer alors écoutez
moi bien oui pierre est un enfant un
gosse un grand gosse prenez le par la
main et je vous en prie je vous en
supplie aider le comprenez le et réalisé
deux enfants à la maison même s'ils se
servent tous deux de leurs petits pois
deux enfants la maison n'est ce pas
merveilleux suez souvenez vous souvenez
vous comme moi je me souviendrai
toujours de vous sylvette souvenez-vous
que pierre qui roule n'amasse pas mousse
oui car tant va la cruche à l'eau
perello le drian
à la fin elle se casse surtout perrette
perrette et le pot tall est bien sûr
enfin que dois-je faire
mimi dégoûté pierer cueilli cueillez dès
aujourd'hui les roses de la vie attaque
au genou
ouvert
bien la mener pour la mort michel boury
saxe est pourri j'aime bien c'est beau
mais c'est bien quand je pense qu'ils
ont fusé sur vidéo de paris branchement
toute manière on n'a rien à regretter un
puisqu'on fait gala du troisième âge des
déboires ont continué de trois quarts
taisez plus chez moi je suis du perron
les crises minorée à toutes les semaines
les vieux les abad les vieux slip les
tomates les nanas qui ravit les restes
de gâteries l'appétit télé c'est plus
chez moi en france et dans deux mois je
vais vous dire les fils un numéro qui va
leur parler broker a fait valoir les
droits la veille par action alors dit on
il faut quand même qu'on renvoie la
chorégraphie sortie de poubelles à
l'état la taxe à la datation ça
que ce soit un problème de salle de bain
il s'est hissé 3,4 c'est moi alors à 2,3
on dit qu'on n'a pas les moules et leur
fils alors c'est vrai on dit que dans
nos villes en dur
la beauté du jura c'est vrai quand les
800 pourri nous on les jette un regard
est pas si nous on ne jette ton si on
dit qu'on est belle mais c'est possible
à la simenon
fais gaffe mais n'oubliez pas ce qu'on
nous a dit on nous a bien prévenu à les
ivoiriens à la moitié qui parlent pas
complètement français
alors c'est notre force aujourd'hui la
mer qu'est la manette lala lala lala
fatma l'aja
la belle mère
l'amour y épousa l'éboueur pas si tu
séparés en plus du salaire il ya des
avantages et la récupération de taille
ce que les gens les jettent dans les
poubelles a comme ordures ouais avec un
k jaws notablement puisqu'à bien tu
parais qu'allez vous remercie que par
exemple dimanche
eh ben il t'amène promener dans sa benne
elle peut t'emmener au bois au pays
resté toute la nuit
elle a relaté dans la belle au bois
dormant et plus de travail ou la nature
du mal mais toute la nuit mont nebo on
dit nancy ont vandalisé vouloir traiter
des poubelles il ya thomas régnier
finale les faux plats amateurs sur wuala
croque la poubelle poubelle par ci
pourrait être cool est variable et se
sait qui semble honnête et puis comme ça
elle vous attend dé pied vous appuyez
sous les draps mais pas du tout c'est la
poubelle papa poubelles poubelle par ci
poubelles poubelle par là mais qu'est ce
que ça va me changer dans ces trucs là
à régis lyon je voulais dire en ce
moment passé c'est super avec les filles
c'est fou cette semaine trois c'est bien
normal
les doigts 50
50 la semaine ouais dans la semaine mais
en bon état tu as un truc non mais non
j'y peux rien c'est comme ça ça tombe
tout seul peut rien y faire c'est
physique pour tatouer ouais ça
s'explique pas tiens tu pourrais montrer
que la demoiselle d'akela tutu montre un
petit peu comment comment il faut faire
en bas non non non non vas-y toi
non non non on a eu trois toits ouais
bah si on accroche te laisse sa nana
mais je revienne tulmont autre registre
non aujourd'hui 50 je préfère rester sur
un chiffre rond
oh là là tous les soirs à 6 heures dans
le métro pour qu'ils prennent le même
que moi j'en ai marre d'être désirables
mais voilà la valeur si je te regarde tu
l'as eu à s'écrouler après alors lotina
envie d'embrasser ça se voit la bouche
pulpeuse ça les attire
il ya d'autres lits mais ils suivent
tous mes clefs ce qu'ils ont j'en ai
assez d'être belle on m'a dit dont je
réalise ses concorde il faut qu'on
descende à cancon mais on m'a serait un
petit peu à la tension
ils ont mis du temps mais ont quand même
compris à s'il vous plaît mademoiselle
vous gardez votre écharpe et voilà ça
leur commence vous croyez quand même pas
je vais tomber dans le piège
non
rendez vous très important aujourd'hui
j'espère que tout va bien se passe dring
en très bon une seconde à l'eau oui new
york
oui alors une seconde je suis en ligne
si vous payez vous patientez un instant
par an à l'eau oui oui
philadelphie oui vous attendez une
seconde s'il voulait parce que je suis
en rendez vous la promesse par mille
pardons attend mais attendez une seconde
s'il vous plaît un oui allô oui c'est
comment rome où il a commis tant attendu
parce que je suis je suis actuellement
chez quelqu'un ici alors je vous
rappelle dans un petit instant un une
seconde voilà monsieur oui c'est
pourquoi je suis agent ptt je reviens
brancher le téléphone
latin dans ce moment de rencontre des
hommes célèbres mais c'est fou tu vois
avant hier tu sais pas ce qui m'est
arrivé mais non je faisais mes courses
je tombe sur qui belmondo tu tombes sur
b le monde
ouais ouais fou fou alors je suis allé
le voir et puis on a commencé à discuter
arrivé alors on est allé boire un coup
après ensemble tu as été boire un coup
avec ben non non mais ouais alors on à
paris cinéma de filmer tout bon c'était
vachement sympa way et après il m'a
proposé de me ramener chez moi en
voiture mais demandant ouais et alors
après ben il m'a demandé s'il pouvait
monter boire un dernier verre tellement
tort web alors là à eux
alors là attention j'ai dit non j'ai
refusé bah c'est vrai quoi belmondo il a
plein de nanas c'est vrai je veux pas
que la dix millième il était vachement
vexé puis ces barrettes hughes a dit non
à belmont dans ouais j'ai dit non à
belmondo didon quoi j'aurais peut-être
pas dû dire oui à alain delon
chères concitoyennes chers concitoyens
si je suis élu maire de crouy je ferai
construire un stade de 60000 places aux
abords de la commune un parking devant
l'église pourra accueillir dix mille
voitures une autoroute reliera
directement la mairie au lavoir couvert
enfin un complexe socioculturel de 8000
spectateurs sera également mise en place
car j'ai à coeur de satisfaire les
trente habitants decrouille vise la
france libre ou du vivre l'écrou ya
alors tu en prison depuis combien de
temps toi ô bon moi ça fait quinze jours
ce cas 15 jours j'ai fait un casse avec
mesrine mesrine
ouais jacques mesrine il est mort il ya
un an
oh mais moi c'est un anatomiste l'insee
c'est un cousin à lui
et toi pourquoi tu es là voici mâchoire
grave s'achever en grave parce que j'ai
violé six femmes
daviau les six femmes d'origine viol ici
pas bon on fait on fait un sketch sur
les mythomanes
c'est pas de la science fiction
nos programmes ce soir si vous restez en
notre compagnie à 20h votre journal qui
sera présenté par christine ockrent qui
a failli est ma mère parce que mon père
l'a rencontré en 1958 à 20h30 votre
grand film de la soirée de dino risi
avec vittorio gassman j'ai couché avec
lui l'été dernier c'était très agréable
merci à 22h30
votre émission médicale je ne vous en
parlerai pas longuement parce que j'ai
fait des études de médecine assez
poussée alors je n'en finirais pas et
j'ai frôlé le prix nobel l'année
dernière à 23 heures votre dernier
journal présenté par hervé claude rca
tout à l'heure on dîne ensemble et bien
excellente soirée parce que à la fin de
trois heures 30 il sera temps de vous
souhaiter une excellente nuit que moi
même j'ai faim serait dans les bras de
robert redford bonsoir à demain